- Ils ont emballé ce
pouvaient, à la hâte.
Certains ont mis psisieurs
jours pour arriver jusqu'ici.
Des vieillards, des mères
et leurs enfants, sans oublier
minou. Trop souvent par contre,
un fils laissés derrière.
Ils ont tenu sous l'occupation
russe pendant des mois.
dernière chance d'y échapper,
croit Ludmilla. Plutôt que les
chars et les
qu'elle espérait, ce sont les
boîtes d'un scrutin référendaire
russe pour l'annexion à la,,,,,,
qu'elle a vu débarquer.
"Ce n'
là, dit-elle. Ils vont de maison
en maison pour recueillir
des signatures avec l'armée.
Si vous n'êtes pas d'accord,
Nous en avons conclu qu'il ne
nous restait que quelques jours
pour partir. Je ne veux pas
voter dans leur référendum,
Impossible de s'exprimer
librement quand on vous demande
de voter avec les armes qui vous
à laquelle une majorité
est arrivée ici.
Relatant des scènes similaires
à ces images que l'on voit
depuis quelques jours dans
les zones paparatistes et sous
occupation russe, beaucoup
confirment les accusations
de ltototototototototototototot)
Pour forcer la participation
r référendum, qualifié
de simulacre par communauté
internationale, c'est
accompagnés de soldats
lourmement armés que le vote
se déroule.
Timothé dit qu'il a bien
"Deux Jeeps sont arrivés
et huit hommes en sont sortis.
Ils ont dit qu'ils étaient
de renseignement russes.
Je ne suis qu'un fonctionnaire
uk
J'étais assis sans rien faire.
Mais je ne pouvais pas partir,
et malade. Je ne pouvais pas
l'abandonner, mais j'ai dû le
un ordre urgent de prendre un
passeport russe, de travailler
de l'annexion au référendum.
Sans quoi, ils m'ont dit
bien différente."
Après sa mère laissé derrière
il se sépare aujourd'hui de
sa femme, qui va vrere à Odessa.
Lui espère pouvoir retrouver
sa mère.
parlé ici refusent de participer
au référendum, un exercice
sur lequel ils ne pensent
Mais surtout, ils craignent
les conséquences d'unennnnexion
à la Russie.
"Nous avons tous peur de devoir
combattre nos propres frères,"
dit Vladimir, qui a mis deux
d'arriver à Zaporijia.
Serioja ne veut pas être
identifié. Il a laissé une
partie de sa famille derrière,e,
quveveulent éviter d'être
conscrits par l'armée russerrrro
esest écrit d'avance par la
Russie." Il ne veut pas du rôle.
"Ils vont venir dans leurs
armes automatiques. Qu'est-ce
qu'un homme peut faire contre
des armes qu'il n'a pas?
Et même avec, ils sont 10 contre
se rebeller. Mais après,
ils vont liquider le vilgege,
l'anéantir. C'est effrayant."
Natasha et sa famille reprennent
des forc
la route pour rejoindre
des proches à Odessa.
"En attendant," dit-elle.
Mais elle redoute que d'ici
la maison qu'elle laisse
derrière ne se retrouve
en territoire russe.
Il nous faud d dire adieu, dit-
elle. C'est déchirant, c'est
effrayant quand on a l'habitude
dans son environnement, dans
sa vil a avec son peuple
de tout abandonner, dans
le rétroviseur."
Mais c'est là, dans leixixixixie
son regard. On n'est jamais tout
à fait prêt au déracinement.